Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. If you're new to the site and new to us, I want to kind of explain what we do and
Some terms that it's easy to understand people will contact us and say how do I get started?
How do I do an alternative approach?
What are the next steps? Well
Let's slow down. Let's take it in steps. It starts with a call. It starts with what really starts actually before the call
Start to do some investigation on our site. See what we do. See what we don't do
We don't do
Integrative care that involves invasive things. You don't have to come to our office. Matter of fact, you can't come to our office. Everything is done in a distance
We don't do anything that puts anything on you. We're not doing care that way
So if you're looking for a clinic that's going to do high-be therapy or looking for a clinic for intervention of, you know
Insulin-potentiated chemotherapy or something like that, then this is not where you should be
This is a clinic where we specialize in nutrition and herbal
Therapies things that God created for us to heal to get better and in
Rife frequency and frequency healing. So you'll see pages on our website about
Rife technology and what that is and how to better understand that. What is Rife technology? What is frequency healing?
You're going to find some videos on that. Please take some time to investigate that because that's really how God let me
Dulled this pathway to help cancer patients from the very beginning. Hey, you know, it was a functional medical
Practitioner doing chiropractic and functional medicine and nutrition and I had a patient come to me say that she had breast cancer and both
Breast and was given three months to live. Well, I have been studying
Rife technology for years, but never felt like
God gave me the permission to buy a rife because goodness, I thought it was just for cancer
Well, now I know it's for a lot more things, but at the time that's what I thought. Well, that was my
Holy spirit aha moment to buy a rife
Because this woman was convinced she was not going to do chemo or radiation
She was going to have her breasts removed, but they gave her three months to live and she'd rather die than go through chemo
That was her mindset. So
That was my moment to get a rife. We bought a rife. She lived for another 13 years
So understand there's a lot of hope
But your hopes got to be placed in him, not in me, not in the rife, not in therapies, not in your own
Our hope can't be misplaced. Our hope is in Christ always
But God can lead you in the direction that you're supposed to go
That's what walking with him is. That's what a walk is
You're praying about the peace that passes all understanding that will come over you
And you know you're doing what you're supposed to do
Now, I am not surprised now looking back that God uses rife technology to heal
rife is light frequencies that God would use light to heal. Oh my gosh
It's like right up his alley, isn't it?
So start with research. You know this site. I have like a thousand blog posts on everything you can possibly think of
We have tons of pages of websites
We have our own video channel because YouTube is constantly taking us down
Powers at B are totally against us
We've been sued by boards. We've been attacked by medical professions and by
By state attorney general offices and I'll probably get in trouble with this video because of what I said
I just don't care anymore because I'm trying to do what God has called me to do
And I just they just kids stop us. They can throw me in jail. They can
Try to, you know, belittle us and poop who everything that we do
but
We just try to help people and we see miracles on a on a regular basis
So don't ever let somebody else tell you or dictate to you what either what you have to do
Or how many days you left to have left in your life if you don't do what they tell you to do
There's no guarantees in life except what God has given us
And I believe that he's numbered my days before the foundations of the earth were set
But I need to walk an obedience to him. We're called to use wisdom. We're called out to be ignorant
Well, that's what we're trying to do in this in this website
It's just give a little piece of knowledge as you can take whether you ever start with us or not
That's okay. Just be obedient to him no matter what you do
If you decide you want to move forward
Then then you can give us a call or we even have a self-schedule page on our website schedule
You know if you're calling looking at our site at midnight on Saturday
You can self-schedule a case review with me but it starts with a case review
That's when we review your case. We look at everything. We talk up together
We try to develop a relationship. I give you some direction if you can't
Come to us for whatever reason. That's okay. We're still going to be praying for you
You can still utilize our services
Um, so we don't we try to make this as much of a ministry as possible
In everything we do if you do schedule a case review with me
It's about a half-hour time where we could go over the phone call you never have to come to our office
Like I said, you can't we're not in in-person clinic
But you call we talk and we discuss what's going on
I can't give you legal medical advice, but I can lead you in different ways and guide you in some wisdom and
And point you in a direction whether it's to work with us in a deeper way
Or it's to just make some different health decisions that will that will help you in your process
If you do decide to work with us then you'll schedule time with onboardy
That's that's staff we have that can help you in the next steps whether you're going to do
Cheekswab test eat or a full comprehensive protocol with us or get a rife with us or whatever you're going to do
Whatever the next steps are you're going to do they'll help you with that and
And walk you through those next steps if we get cheek swabs from you
You have to give us some time to get those processed and tested
We test for what we think is the cause and what we think are going to be the best cancer balancers in your
Situation what your diet should be we give you a complete binder printed out
We also can send that in an email formula
Form for you to start working through we program your rife
Specifically for you different nights of the week different programming. It's a day program
So that you're using that as as much as you possibly can to get your healing underway
Hello, will it take to get better? Hello. Will it take to see
Improvement we have videos on that too everybody's different obviously, but we see people start to feel better pretty quick. So
Biggest thing is change your mindset. There's always hope
God is in control in all things use wisdom use the
Brain that he gave you to seek knowledge and through that just be praying that the Holy Spirit guides you
He will he's promised that you ask wisdom. He'll freely give that to you
And he'll give you the peace that you need to know that you're doing the right thing
Know that regardless of what decision you make we're we're going to be praying for you. God has sovereigned all things
We believe that he still heals nothing has changed about God and nothing will
Know that we'll be praying for you no matter what you do feel free to look through our website
Use all the resources that we have and we just pray that you'll be blessed